[موسيقى]
لا اريد ان اقول ان الادله كلها التي
قدمتها الولايات المتحده ولكن كل ما قدمته
الولايات المتحده علنا كان يستنده في شكل
كبير الى وقائع غير صحيحه واعتقد ان كولن
باول الذي كان وزير خارجيه وقتها اقر بذلك
لاحقا عندما التقيته لانني سافرت ايضا الى
الولايات المتحده لاشرح الموقف الفرنسي
ولم يكن الامر دائما سهلا ولكن معنى ذلك
ذهبت الى هناك
لم يكن موافقا تماما او لنقل لم يكن اتمنى
موقفا الرئيس بشرى عندما التقيته
[موسيقى]
كذلك التقيت كنده ليسرايس وقتها وقلت لها
انتبهي انما تقومون به خطا العراق بلد
تعددي صحيح ان موقعه مهم ولكن هناك مواقف
مختلفه وقد نخاطر بخلق منطقه غير مستقره
التقيت كونداليزا رايس لاحقا فقالت لي لم
تكوني على خطا امامنا في تحليلك للوضع كان
ذلك بعد الحرب بوقتا طويل ولكنه كان
اقرارا مهما
[موسيقى]